welcome back to new rockstars I'm Eric
Voss in the Avengers burst open the
Marvel Cinematic Universe with proud fan
service self-aware humor and cool
collaborative action really I guess just
things collaborating off caps shield and
it's set vanos on a warpath to kill in
half these freaks well none of these
freaks since they're the important
freaks in these post endgame times let
us now appreciate the adventure sharp
attention to detail by paying attention
to the details and makes a privacy calm
for sponsoring this episode if you sign
up now at privacy icon slash new rock
stars you can get $5 today to use on any
purchase online ok the Marvel Studios
title reveals its within the tesseract
literally framing all of this within
Infinity stones
Loki returns with an army of Chitauri
Lukey's the thrilling comeback here
introduces the Avengers deeper theme of
redemption in order to avenge anything
you must first lose it
The Avengers aren't undefeated studs
they're dirty misfit toys rally at
halftime cuz we can't protect the Earth
you can be damn well sure we'll avenge
it
[Music]
and we open on project Pegasus
researching the tesseract recovered by
Howard Stark
Captain Marvel actually revealed how
Pegasus was used to help the scrolls in
the in-between period and it's believed
that the Helicarrier cloaking tech might
have come from those Scrolls Nick Fury
Coulson and Maria hill meet Clint Barton
Hawkeye and Erik Selvig and Loki arrives
he now looks paler his eyes darker is
less than the Shakespearean Prince now
straight up evil and and has no quarrel
with the boot and that light of course
comes back later and
buuut Luke he uses his scepters mind
stone to flip Clint solving and shield
soldiers and the escape then Tasha
Romanov Black Widow faces the Looch Cove
an enemy in the comics and Coulson calls
her and on his screen is the name Steven
Wharton one of the VFX artists for the
film natasha tracks down Bruce Banner
now recast as Mark Ruffalo and he hints
at the secret to his anger management
avoiding stress isn't the secret we
later learn his big secret his control
over his anger is what that incredible
whole final shot was actually all about
Natasha briefs them on the tesseract
what does fury bump you smell it
actually swallowing the tesseract is
exactly what fury had goose do some of
the agents outside have blue glowing
weapons foreshadowing shield secret
agenda to build on hydras mission of
tesseract powered weaponry fury convenes
with a board including Gideon Malick who
also shows up in agents of shield which
is why you should be focusing on Phase
two
it was designed for exactly these two
isn't ready in this movie Phase two is
the plan to roll out tesseract powered
weapons sled it's also of course a nod
to the Marvel Studios Phase two schedule
which would begin after this movie Steve
Rogers boxes now many believe this is
Daredevils fogwell gym but you know that
really isn't specified cap bursts a bag
a not by director Joss Whedon to his
series Buffy notice the old school file
that fury gives cap there's some barely
readable text at the bottom mentioning
misto and infinity gems so Marvel
released a redacted version of this but
the text doesn't really match what's in
the movie Mephisto is Marvel's devil
figure and in the Infinity Gauntlet
comics he is right at the nose decide as
he clicks the infinity gems this
paragraph looks to me like an alternate
backstory that Marvel was considering
for the Infinity Saga storyline fury
makes him a bet at this point I doubt I
think would surprise me ten bucks says
you're wrong later on on the Helicarrier
cap follows through on the bet
Iron Man installs a power line to his
new start tower later Loki will exploit
this energy source to open the portals
dark always build the instruments of his
own destruction
actually our first image of him is a
close-up of his right gauntlet the same
hand that he will later used to
permanently end this war that begins in
this movie good to go on this
just like indicating tony was good to go
and now the rest is up to us tony has
moved back to his home city of New York
and they added the Tower of the MetLife
building Marvel actually got approval to
include the Oscorp tower in the city
skyline but the okay came after the VFX
artist had already rendered everything
Tony and pepper joke about how much
credit she deserves
give yourself 12 percent its credit 12
percent an argument can be made for 15
we were having a moment I was having 12
percent of a moment it's actually a
similar joke in guardians of the galaxy
I don't know 12 percent 12 percent to
all conspiracy oh no the numbers 12 and
17 tend to come up a lot and movies do
to a screenwriting thing with 12 being a
one-syllable number more than 10 that
doesn't slow down a joke spacing and 17
being a weirdly specific prime number
that isn't too many of something
stark tells Coulson you've reached the
life model decoy of Tony Stewart please
leave a message
life model decoys our Android doubles in
the comics LM DS also show up in agents
of shield and they discuss the towers in
secure elevator security breach
Tony will remember this breach when he
sneaks back in here during the in game
time Heights never reveals that
Coulson's first name is filip his first
name is agent the first Iron Man script
referred to Coulson only as Agent
Coulson no first name given and pulses
file includes footage from other phase 1
MCU movies pepper and Tony asked Coulson
about a cellist girlfriend
think back to Portland so understand
take a weekend I'll fly into this
cellist is Audrey Nathan and Coulson
meets Aaron agents of shield Coulson cap
discussed these super soldiers serums
connection to Hulk and cap misses is
Stephen Hawking reference along with
almost every pop culture reference in
this movie they can use reindeer games
what Rock of Ages given up so easily
I'll never be that easy
no hard feelings Point Break you got a
mean swing and of course Point Break
comes back in thor ragnarok Point Break
welcome Point Break but cap does get
flying monkeys to his personal flying
monkeys I understood that reference
because of course the Wizard of Oz came
out in 1939 before a cap wit in the ice
Coulson consider his old man cap to be
an asset people might just need a little
old-fashioned fury brings up this
description later when eulogizing
Coulson it's an old-fashioned emotion
and Natasha uses similar wording for
banner later no we could use a little
words during our discord watch along our
friend teens revealed Johansson echoes
Clark Greg's exact cadence which she
learned from an audio w project very
cool
you can join our future watch long as my
becoming a patron at patreon.com slash
new rock stars natasha wears red and
black banner wears purple their
signature comic colors and the bridge of
the carrier with its rows of monitors
and raised platforms was designed to
reflect the wings of the shield logo
they discussed tracking Loki we're
sweeping every wirelessly accessible
camera on the planet cell phones laptops
notice cap here sitting right next to
him is Sitwell who shortly after he uses
facial recognition to find Loki but we
got a hit sixty-seven percent match yeah
cap doesn't feel right about how
powerful shield is at spying on people
it's his core conflict and Winter
Soldier when Sitwell is revealed as a
Hydra agent and Natasha his future
alliance with Kappas into that later
shield monitors monitor the cap
confronts Loki in Germany the last time
I was in Germany it saw a man standing
above everybody else we ended up
disagreeing and as he passes them the
liberated people start to stand up Tony
arrives calling back is a CDC shoot to
thrill from Iron Man 2 but Thor
interferes drone would suit you
these Ravens are hugging a moon in
Odin's earth spies
so Odin is watching his sons right here
four Birds marbles Holy Trinity do get
out Thor shocks Ironman but after fixing
the mark fives flaws now the electric
current is an asset powerful hundred
percent opacity how about that
notice that the suit is that four
hundred seventy five percent power here
and then later in the movie it is down
to three hundred twelve percent which if
you think about it means at Tony's
battles in the movies second act alone
expended the energy equivalent of about
one and a half Iron Man's this melee
later inspires the big moves against
Thanos stark channels Thor's lightning
and cap uses the Mjolnir shield
shockwave here to later knocks a nose
down and after entertaining them they
discussed Loki that guy's brain is a bag
full of cats it could smell crazy on him
originally hopes later fight with Loki
was going to feature Loki projecting
duplicates of himself and Hulk was gonna
have to sniff out the real one using
Loki's sense Tony arrives wearing a
Black Sabbath shirt amount to the band
song I am Iron Man
that man is playing Galaga thought we
wouldn't notice but we did yeah pest
joke ever at the end of the scene if you
think about it Tony's confrontation with
the endlessly swarming Chitauri fleet
through the portal is in a sense a game
of Galaga and out by the way we later
got confirmation that Galaga guy was
among the dusted Tony tells Bruce your
work on antielectron collisions is
unparalleled in physics the collisions
of anti electrons or positrons are what
emit gamma radiation later he tells
Bruce that much gamma exposure should
have killed you so you're saying that
the Hulk the other guy saved my life
that's nice it's a nice sentiment saved
it for what guess we'll find out you may
not enjoy that
yeah and since Infinity stones emit
gamma radiation Tony is talking about
his future death Tony also talks some
[ __ ] on cap that's the guy my dad never
shut up about wondering if they
shouldn't kept him on ice Tony's
grievance with cap is tied in with his
own daddy issue Howard worshipped cap
and didn't give Tony enough love it's
interesting our earlier cap echoed this
frustration with our over leaving things
in the past there anything you can tell
us about the tesseract that we ought to
know now you should have left it in the
ocean well folks more people than ever
are working from home shopping from home
schooling from home
letting the soothing sounds of Anthony
Hopkins as a Odin calm or anxiety from
home and with that extra time online
there's more opportunity than ever for
hackers to steal your information or
your money well thanks to privacy comm
for sponsoring this video
privacy lets you make online purchases
using virtual burner cards for online
purchases this protects your identity
and your bank information on the
internet and lets you control the limits
on each virtual card that comes in handy
with the streaming services or video
conferencing apps that we're all using
right now so for example I've set up an
account with privacy I've linked my bank
account and I created a card
specifically for my monthly Netflix
subscription payment privacy will ding
you with lightning-fast precision if
someone tries to charge that card twice
or if the charge exceeds the amount you
set for it no vendor could overcharge
beyond the limit that you have set it's
simple it's fast it's really just one
click they also offer different plans
there's a free plan that lets you create
up to 12 cards a month a pro plan where
you can get 36 cards a month and 1% cash
back on purchases and the team's plan
for small businesses and there's a
privacy Chrome extension where you can
fill out all of your card info to save
time one click and all your details are
instantly entered head to privacy comm
slash new rockstars to sign up for an
account and as a special treat for my
viewers new customers will automatically
get five dollars to spend on your first
purchase for a limited time only by
Odin's beard that's free money go to
privacy icon slash new rockstars to sign
up now ok the phase 2 weapon recap
fights has Hydra logos smoking gun that
shield is effectively a regrown head of
Hydra in etosha chats with Loki can he
wipe out that much red
drei coughs daughter sour powder the
hospital fire the Black Widow prelude
comics reveal general Dre cough oversaw
the Red Room so maybe the movie will
reveal Nats past with his daughter and
then everyone fights take that off what
are you genius billionaire playboy
philanthropist you're not the guy to
make the sacrifice play everything
special about you me I'm a bottle of
course these men prove each other wrong
in the long run
cap strength comes from his own innate
worthiness and Tony again and again an
MCU makes the sacrifice play meanwhile
banner gets dark I put a bullet in my
mouth and the other guys spit it out
actually this suicide attempt was a
deleted scene from the Norton Hulk film
and throughout these moments the camera
tilts into Dutch angles pushing in on
Loki's scepter and inverting reflecting
how the mine stone is corrupting
everyone the final framing even suggests
the scepter is calling them holding the
Avengers by the neck and right before
the attack banners computer reveals the
tesseracts in New York explaining how he
knows where to meet them and head Tony
not bitched at cap here Tony would have
been able to stop the portal hours
earlier and save countless lives as
banner Hulk's out behind him are the 15
words of warning under pressure and that
tries to calm him down
my life I will get you out of this you
will walk away in age of Ultron Natasha
continues to try to help banner walk
away from Hulk and as we learn in our
hole Kree watch they all make the
mistake of calling Hulk Bruce or banner
which he hates
we're not your enemies Donna try to make
redirects is rage to the fighter pilots
able to focus enough to stop the ejector
seat to think about it Hulk was right to
go for these pilots since they're the
ones who fire the nukes and Coulson
tries to stop Loki with a weapon based
on the destroyer armor its barrel warms
up similarly to the destroyer now
Coulson resurrects and agents of shield
via project Tahiti but his death here
was me failure that gives the Avengers
something to avenge this was never gonna
work they didn't have something fury
ribs and that guilt with cap trading
cards that he creepily smeared Coulson's
blood on the card depicts caps first
comic book appearance reminding cap that
the kids who ravenously read the Hitler
punch cap number one included at some
point history a young Phil Coulson and
banner meets this dude you knew lien
what Harry Dean Stanton played Brett an
alien my favorite movie cap uses the
glitchy mark six armor to make Loki
think he's on his last leg but saving
the mark seven armor as a surprise move
notice how he also keeps his arms behind
his back and stays behind barriers so
that Loki hopefully won't notice his
wrists were bare when he walked in what
have I to fear the Avengers Earth's
Mightiest Heroes time frame of course
Tony's quoting The Avengers tagline and
behind him on the bar is the framed
photo of him and pepper that was taken
of them in Monaco in Iron Man 2 and they
negotiate I have an army we have a Hulk
there is no version of this where you
come out on top here actually is a
version of history in which Loki escapes
thanks to Tony's clumsiness during the
time heist in endgame Loki's scepter
fails on Tony fueling the theory that
Tony's arc reactor is powered by space
stone drive tech that neutralizes the
mind stone here in Tony deploys a marked
seven armor and as the portal opens note
that Tony's heads-up display switches to
all red to show his switch into
offensive mode Loki tricks the world
with sentiment and sticks him with a
dagger these same kind of move he tries
to pull on Fanus an infinity war doesn't
work around too well and plinth in a
touch of remember nature's steam pass
you will now remember Budapest very
differently the pest is a location in
the upcoming Black Widow movie and we
may finally learn what that mission was
cap give some orders to some cops the
younger one is the same actor who played
agent Sousa and agent Carter and
throughout this battle or shots of a
waitress
Beth played by Ashley Johnson Chrissy
Seaver from growing pains and the voice
of Ellie in the Last of Us there was a
lot of deleted scenes that showed Beth
as a waitress that cap had a crush on
Pam as year as long as you like
nobody's way to go that is for her don't
be a [ __ ] and banner returns resumes
being angry and takes em to Leviathan to
give them the hero shots so perfect they
had to bring it back an end game Tony
shows maturity here by crediting others
doors right we got a deal with these
guys call it captain and cap learns are
the best way to work with Hulk is to
call him by his name and Hulk smash this
battle showcases collaboration Ironman
boosts Hokkaido rooftop Hawkeye directs
Tony to lure the Chitauri into a Killa
box caps shield Springs Natasha Sweden
highlights the connection between all
these heroes with a tracking shot Tony
and Natasha Tony and cap Tony and
Hawkeye Hawkeye and Hulk Hulk and Thor
and we never cut through this because
the link between the Avengers is now
unseparable until Hulk severs it really
the best hits of this battle are taken
by the demigods Hulk says beauty God as
a way to up the ante kind of bring it on
to whatever God's may be watching Tony
evokes the tale of Jonah from the Bible
whom Jarvis quips is not the best role
model Jonah if you think about it got
swallowed by a whale after throwing
himself overboard to save his crew so
ironically Jonah's sacrifice blade does
make him a good role model for Tony and
when he lands afterward behind him is
the shawarma restaurant where they get
lunch in the post-credits scene and they
deploy nukes
thirty seconds mark time this because
exactly two minutes and thirty seconds
later in the movies runtime the nuke
detonates
tony has a countdown timer in his
heads-up display that stays consistent
Jarvis shows his evolving humanity by
calling pepper for Tony
the way Tony looks at her photo mirrors
away cap looks at peggy's photo when he
made the sacrifice place and the extreme
closeup on Tony's eyes as he takes in
the cosmos is later mirrored by the shot
of cap and in game the first time he
leaves the Earth's atmosphere Alan
Silvestri's dramatic music that builds
up to Tony's moment of truth is actually
later echoed exactly in Tony's moment of
truth an end game inevitable
right as Tony crosses through that
portal his descent accelerates since
he's now suddenly within Earth's
atmosphere in the force of gravity
stronger Hulk roars I'm awake what just
happened we won
these words are mirrored with an inverse
exchange an endgame again Tony we lost
in the news footage Beth be deleted
waitress shows up along with Stanley who
plays chess in the same area where
magneto plays chess in x-men the last
and the file name in the corner is a 113
the famous Cal arts classroom that
artists always sneak into movies we see
the Iron Man art in the Obey style from
Iron Man 2 and criticizing them as
senator Boynton who in the comics
authorizes Project firepower against
Iron Man Tony and pepper review hologram
plans for Avengers Tower which include a
garage for the Quinjet and several logos
tony designed for each avenger the
movies post credits scenes reveal the
true villain of the Infinity Saga Danos
[Music]
in his smile nods to lady death being
Thanos's love interest and courting her
being his motive for the Infinity
Gauntlet storyline but behind him is a
planet cracked in half
visually foreshadowing his ultimate goal
of wiping out half the universe a second
post-credits scene of course returns to
this warmer restaurant notice how Chris
Evans is covering his face because he
grew a beard for his next role in
snowpiercer but the movie's official
final image reveals the New Avengers
tower which reflects this movie's deeper
theme of redemption
Tony built this tower as a shrine to
himself and his own towering pride but
it's very existence gives Loki a key to
unleash hell on the city however after
learning how to collaborate the Avengers
avenge their failures into a key to
their victory and now the symbol of
Tony's folly has transformed into a
symbol of his success once he was a
stark now he is an Avenger how does the
adventures ring for you in the MCU look
folks this is vanity saga rewatch is
moving on to phase 2 baby
join our watch lungs on discord by
becoming a patron at patreon.com slash
new rockstars comment down below with
your thoughts follow me on instagram and
twitter at EA vas follow new rockstars
and subscribe to this channel so that we
can all together watch Tony Stark take
some nut shots
[Music]